[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 78 il est
18h si vous nous rejoignez en direct sur
tvil 78 dans ce 31 janvier nous allons
cuisiner ensemble bonsoir tout d'abord à
Sylvie Kempler merci d'être en plateau
avec nous vous êtes professeur de
cuisine vous donner des cours dans votre
atelier à plaisir donc pour les petits
et pour les grands vous allez nous en
parler dans dans un instant plaisir
justement c'est la commune où est
installée l'entreprise le nôtre le nôtre
où travaille notamment thbao rudgeri
c'est le nouveau bocus d'or et vous le
savez si vous étiez avec nous hier à la
même heure nous avons découvert ensemble
le palmarès de cette olympiade de la
gastronomie et les réaction de Tibor
oueri ce sera dans un instant dans cette
édition du 78 pour le moment voici les
titres les principaux sujets en images
la mobilisation des agents de la
fonction publique dans l'éducation
nationale un mouvement peu suivi dans
les ivelines seulement 18 % de greviste
nous avons fait le point sur
l'agglomération la France je vous le
disais a remporté le bcus d'or 2013 des
Jeux Olympique de la cuisine trophée
empoché par thbao rudgeri chef adjoint
de la création salée chez le nôtre à
plaisir en football 32e de finale de la
Coupe de France les féminines de Montini
le Bretonneux sèchement battu par le PSG
9 à0 la logique est respectée et les
filles se concentrent maintenant sur le
maintien en championnat de 2e division
division et puis l'affaire Gaston
Dominici revu et peut-être corrigé par
les étudiants en droit de l'Université
de Versailles Saint-Quentin
l'association juris tribune propose tous
les ans une reconstitution de procès et
ils seront d'ailleurs en plateau avec
nous tout à l'heure et puis dans une
demi-heure la chronique de l'écho avec
Claire Cambier bonsoir claire bonsoir wi
ce sera le rendez-vous chcho votre
premier rendez-vous chcho bienvenue au
sein de la rédaction de TVfil 78 il y
aura deux thématiques développées ce
soir ravi de de vous rejoindre aussi
effectivement nous aborderons deux
sujets tous deux liés à la création
d'entreprise alors tout d'abord le
microcrédit pour cela nous recevrons la
responsable Eveline de ladi
l'Association pour le droit à
l'initiative économique cette
association lance du 4 au 8 février la
semaine du microcrédit en partenariat
avec la Chambre des Métiers et puis nous
enchaînerons sur le concours talent de
la BGE qui récompense les créateurs
d'entreprisees merci Claire et donc à
tout à l'heure en seconde partie
d'édition du 78 et je vous le disais en
titre mobilisation donc dans la fonction
publique aujourd'hui la première depuis
l'élection de François Hollande du
socialiste principale revendication les
salaires et les enseignants aussi
étaient dans la rue
reportage grève des fonctionnaires ce
jeudi dans les ivelines dans l'éducation
nationale au total seulement 18 % du
personnel était en grève ils réclam une
hausse de leur salaire et protestent
contre la suppression de poste c'est la
première grève menée par la CGT FSU
solidaire depuis le début du quinquen de
François Hollande c'est la première
c'est une façon de prendre date sur la
défense des services publics qui ont été
très mal menés ces 10 dernières années
et qui en dehors de l'éducation continue
à l'être dans le projet de budget la
grève est peu suivie dans
l'agglomération la plus grande
mobilisation se situe à trappe au total
SEP écoles ont fermé quatre maternelles
et trois primaires à voisin lebreteneux
seul l'école de la pépinière n'a pas
ouvert ses portes ce matin dans les
autres communes les établissements
étaient ouverts mais certains services
ne sont pas assurés à La Verrière il n'y
a pas de garderie de restauration ni
d'animation dans les écoles du bois de
l'étan et du parc élémentaire le service
minimum est en revanche mise en place à
Montini le bretenux car 25 %
d'enseignants sont grèvistes les
fonctionnaires étaient 5,2 millions à
être appelés à la grève ce jeudi à
travers 120 points de
rassemblement et le gouvernement qui a
annoncé au cours de la journée qu'il n'y
aurait pas de revalorisation générale
des salaires de prévus la phrase du jour
du 78 qui va s'afficher dans un instant
elle est signée du président du conseil
général des yelines mais aussi du député
maire de Versailles et des présidents
des chambres de commerce des Yvelines et
de Paris il s'exprime à propos du Grand
Paris Express ce futur super métro il
convient d'ors et déjà de s'orienter
vers une solution de type métro léger la
réalisation de ce système de transport
beaucoup moins coûteuse doit pouvoir
être étudiée dès 2013 et cette phrase
cette citation est extraite d'un
courrier à destination de Jean-Marc ko
le Premier ministre doit d'ici 3
semaines rendre les d'arbitrage sur
l'ordre de priorité de ce projet de 200
km de ligne et de 72 nouvelles gares les
élus locaux qui craignent de voir les
réalisations dans ce secteur des
Yvelines repousser à au-delà de 2030 il
demande donc une solution plus légère
mais surtout plus rapide nous
reviendrons sur ces informations au
cours de nos prochaines éditions au
début de la semaine prochaine mais
maintenant je vous l'avais promis place
à la cuisine est-ce vraiment si facile
et c'est la première invitée de ce soir
qui va nous le
[Musique]
dire Sylvie Kempler vous êtes donc
professeur de cuisine à plaisir vous y
avez ouvert en décembre dernier un
atelier et votre light motif c'est la
cuisine c'est facile est-ce que c'est
vraiment si facile la cuisine mais tout
à fait tout à fait il suffit de prendre
les choses dans le bon sens et euh tout
marche très bien et c'est ce que je veux
faire comprendre mes élèves dans les
cours c'est qu'avec des bons produits de
saison on peut faire des résultats
magnifiques alors peut-être pas aussi
technique que ce que a fait Tibo Jerry
mais on arrive quand même à des très
belles choses parce que aujourd'hui tout
le monde dit on le voit aussi avec les
différentes émissions télé que la
cuisine véritablement c'est facile mais
ça reste un métier ça s'apprend
également par exemple votre formation
tout alors j'ai un CAP de cuisine j'ai
travaillé en restaurant et chez un
traiteur et tous les jours je fais des
nouvelles recettes ou moi j'essaie de
faire des nouvelles recettes d'après des
grands chefs parce que mon autre toc
c'est de corriger leurs livres et de
réécrire leurs recettes donc j'ai plein
d'idées dans la tête et je me rends
compte qu'on peut rendre les choses très
simple à notre niveau pour le quotidien
par contre par exemple si vous avez
toujours été dans ce ce milieu de la
gastronomie ce qu'on peut peut-être
mentionner aussi c'est que c'est une
reconversion un petit peuessionnel que
vous avez mené fait tout à fait j'étais
historien de l'art au départ puis
éditeur et mon tout ce tient tout tout
est lié quand on aménage une assiette
qu'on la présente c'est un tableau et
quand quand on regarde des produits sur
un étal c'est aussi un tableau on voit
quelques images de de vos ateliers
justement on découvrira ce reportage
dans dans quelques instants vous me
disiez avant de débuter cette émission
dès l'âge de 15 ans vous auriez eu envie
justement de vous lancer dans cette
profession tout à fait mais bon à
l'époque c'était pas très courant
d'avoir des femmes en cuisine c'était un
peu passé de mode parce qu'il y avait eu
les mes entre les deux guerres et
maintenant ça revient et j'en suis ravie
et je suis heureux aujourd'hui de
transmettre c'est une frustration pour
vous justement de ne pas pouvoir être
justement derrière les fourneaux pas du
tout pas du tout au contraire je suis
ravie d'avoir pu faire cette carrière
alors le déclic s'est fait comment le
déclic s'est fait comment à quel moment
vous vous êtes dit bon ça y est je le
sais j'ai envie je veux que ça change ah
j'avais toujours eu envie je me suis
retrouvé au chômage et grâce à mon mari
B j'ai pu passer mon Capp de cuisinier
parce qu'il m'a soutenu dans mon projet
il m'a dit va faire ce que tu as
toujours voulu faire va faire ta passion
et aujourd'hui ces ateliers qui sont
donc ouverts du côté de plaisir on va
parler des cours que vous est dispensé
et si l'on parle cuisine ce soir c'est
aussi bien évidemment car la France a
remporté le bocus d'or 2013 ces Jeux
olympiques de la cuisine lancé en 1987
par le grand chef Paul Bocuse un trophée
qui a été empoché par Tibao rudgeri le
chef adjoint de la création salée chez
le nôtre à plaisir sa réaction
recueillie ce matin par Catherine
zulato champion olympique de cuisine
c'est ainsi que l'on peut appeler
aujourd'hui thbo rudgeri chef adjoint de
la création salée chez le nôtre à
plaisir qui vient de décrocher le bus
d'or c'était ce mercredi soir à Lyon et
ce jeudi matin au téléphone la voix un
peu éraillée par la nuit qu'il vient de
passer et que l'on devine longue Tibo
rudgeri savoure son prix on a partagé ça
cétait important de faire la fête avec
tous les compatriotes et tous les
candidats et tous ceux qui ont cru et
qui nous ont supporté depuis hier 18h
c'est des photos des interviews c'est
autre chose mais ça fait partie du dile
donc une immense joie une immense fierté
euh sachant qui avait grosse
responsabilité de représenter la France
donc euh vraiment extrêmement content et
énormément d'émotions pour pour moi et
toute l'équipe qui était euh de chez le
nôre avec qui j'ai fait les plats qui
m'ont aidé d'une manière exceptionnelle
cette compétition du bocus d'or existe
depuis 1987 elle réunit tous les 2 ans
24 chefs du monde entier thbo ruderi a
remporté ce prix sous les yeux de son
coach Fabrice Prochasson le jeune homme
a découvert la cuisine à l'âge de 11 ans
en inventant comme il l'a appelé son
gâteau poubelle une sorte de quatre/4
une inventivité aux apparences toutes
simples qu'il a donc mené aujourd'hui au
sommet le dernier bocus d'or pour la
France remonte à 2007 on parlait des
femmes en cuisine tout à l'heure on
c'est pas mentionné dans le reportage
mais on peut le préciser la la commie de
Tibo Reri était la seule femme de la
compétition à occuper ce ce poste hein
quelle est votre réaction peut-être
justement à cette victoire de la France
ouais je trouve ça génial et que on ait
remporté ce bouse euh et puis j'ai
trouvé que c'était une grande émotion
voyant la remise des prix hier je suis
j'ai juste une petite frustration
j'aimerais être en cuisine pendant qu'il
prépare les plats pour voir comment ils
font on imagine qu'il y a beaucoup de
pression hein justement mais c'est pas
si médiatisé que ça he ceci dit si on
ouvre juste une petite parenthèse par
rapport à la situation dans les pays du
Nord par exemple de l'Europe ou même du
Japon ils sont venus avec des des
centaines de supporters à Lyon pour
assister à la manifestation ça pas pris
pareil en France comment vous expliquez
ça je n'en sais rien la France c'est le
pays de la gastronomie pour on défend
pas nos chefs alors on est trop gâté on
ils sont là donc voilà on se déplace
peut-être moins mais je sais quand même
qu'il y avait beaucoup de supporters à
Lyon parce que j'ai une ami qui m'en a
parlé à midi qui en venait la France se
repose pas trop sur ses acquill en
matière de cuisine parce que c'est
toujours la référence mais il faut faire
attention aux autres pays aussi alors je
suis très admiratif des pays du Nord que
je ne connais pas mais VO à travers ce
que je
vois et ça fait plusieurs fois qu'il
remporte des prix soit la Norvège ou la
Suède ou le Danemark je trouve ça
extraordinaire que des pays qui son sont
a priori pas gastronomique puisse
remporter ce prix créé par la France et
vous pensez que justement avec ce prix
ça peut créer encore un engouement
autour B des différents ateliers une
fois de plus autour de de la cuisine
d'une manière générale donner au vie aux
gens de retourner derrière les fourneaux
j'espère on va parler justement de ces
ateliers vous les avez ouvert en
décembre la fréquentation est-ce que ça
marche bien justement ça se développe
très bien tout doucement mais bien de
manière continue et au début c'était
surtout des gens que je connaissais qui
sont venus de mon village et ou des
connaissances que j'avais d'avant des
cours que je donnais depuis depuis des
années et maintenant c'est grâce à
internet que je me fais connaître et
comment se passe les cours c'est entre
1h et 3h et à peu près oui ça peut être
aussi un cours la journée mais à priori
je ne fais pas ça parce que je sais que
c'est très fatiguant mais parce qu'on a
la tension qui retombe et je fais des
cours faciles au en 1hure ou 45 minutes
où je montre qu'on peut faire un plin et
un dessert très vite qu'on remporte à la
maison mais aussi des choses un peu plus
élaboré en 2 ou 3 heures que l'on peut
manger sur place ou que l'on peut
remporter il y a pas de prérequis on n
pas besoin de connaître un petit peu
déjà la cuisine même quelqu'un qui n
connaît strictement rien peut venir dans
votre cuisine tout même si on ne sait
pas casser un œuf on peut venir alors
effectivement on part de très loin là
même si on ne sait pas casser un œuf je
parle de vécu vous avez eu des gens
justement le profil des gens qui
viennent vous voir de tout petit grand
plus ou moins passionnés des gens qui
veulent ouvrir une Chambre d'autes qui
se disent bon il faut que je prenne des
cours de cuisine que je m'entraîne des
gens passionnés des gens qui se disent
ah ça ça me plairait bien qu' se le font
offrir par leur famille c'est un cadeau
de Noël un cadeau d'anniversaire donc il
y a toutes les forme il y a des cours
ponctuels ou aussi des abonnements on
peut venir plusieurs fois tout au long
de l'année exactement j'ai des groupes
qui viennent régulièrement une fois par
mois et d'autres une fois pour apprendre
juste un sujet et puis qui reviennne un
en après ou 6 mois après et j'ai les
enfants qui reviennent le plus souvent
pour le anniversaire ils veulent revenir
l'année suivante oui parce que
effectivement vous préparez les goûterés
d'anniversaire vous accueillez plusieurs
enfants tout au long de la journée voilà
alors c'est deux formules soit c'est le
déjeuner d'anniversaire il prépare une
entrée un plat un dessert ensemble qu'on
déguste tout ensemble ensuite et sinon
l'autre formule c'est plus pâtisserie et
ça c'est le vrai goûter d'anniversaire
et ils font des petits gâteaux qui
remportent à la maison mais il déguste
aussi sur place le gâteau d'anniversaire
qu'ils ont décoré mais il y a tout de
même un âge minimum c'est 8 ans hein
c'est ça pour pouvoir participer au
moins être à l'aise ne pas ne pas faire
de bétisse dans la cuisine parce qu'il
faut tout de même y faire attention il y
a un prix j'imagine la cuisine c'est
facile mais est-ce que ça coûte cher non
pas du tout on va pas donner les prix de
l'ensemble des cours parce que j'imagine
que c'est très différent diff on veut
suivre un cours très ponctuel de 2 he
par exemp un componctuel de 2h c'est
entre 40 et 50 € 60 € pour le fois gras
parce que c'est un produit un petit peu
plus cher mais globalement c'est 50 €
pour 2 heur de cours et vous repartez
avec ce que vous avez fait la semaine
dernière j'ai donné un cours macaron mes
élèves sont partis avec une bonne
vingtaine de macarons chacun est-ce que
vous avez aussi le le sentiment de
surfer un petit peu sur cette vague des
émissions de télévision autour de la
cuisine pas du tout pas du tout je je me
sors un petit peu à part parce que je
suis débordée par mon métier et je nai
pas le temps de suivre ce qui se passe à
la télévision non je suis pas une bonne
spectatrice vous en pensez quoi toutes
ces émissions justement même si vous
n'avez pas le temps de les regarder
c'est P très bien oui c'est très positif
parce que surtout auprès des jeunes je
me rends compte qu'ils sont admiratifs
de ces chefs et que ça leur donne envie
et qu'ils ont aussi envie de faire des
choses à la maison et ça je trouve ça
génial effectivement on voit sur ces
images encore toutes ces grandes chaînes
de télévision qui multiplient les
émissions télé comme vous les regardez
pas je vais pas vous demander si c'est
fidèle à la réalité mais dans vos
cuisines est-ce qu'il y a une pression
est-ce que quand il faut envoyer il faut
envoyer parce que dans les vraie
cuisines quand faut y aller faut y aller
hein voilà temps en temps non non non je
fais je fais ça cool et de temps en
temps je joue le jeu en disant allez on
y va mais c'est plutôt sous forme
humoristique on va se rendre dans votre
atelier justement à présent le jour de
notre passage vous aviez réalisé une
tarte au citron c'est meringué on
regarde plus j'ai choisi des citrons qui
viennent de Nice parce qu'ils sont très
doux et c'est des citrons bio et qui ont
un goût beaucoup plus subtil que les
citrons qu'on trouve en général au menu
du jour la la tarte au citron meringué
le chef Sylvie Kempler dispense ses
cours de cuisine sucré ou salé depuis
décembre à plaisir que les gens ont
besoin d'AP prendre les bases de la
cuisine et pour le groupe qui la r parti
de découvrir la cuisine française sur la
table beurre sucre glace
œufs des produits issus de l'agriculture
raisonné voire bio et principalement de
producteurs locaux farine du Moulin de
Versailles beurre de Grignon œu de
rambouiller la pâtisserie demande
précision et rigueur et pas un GAM
supplémentaire qui pourrait modifier la
structure du Mai tout le monde refait
après et avec plaisir et je reçois des
petits mails en disant j'ai réussi et ça
pour moi c'est la grande satisfaction
parce que pour moi la cuisine c'est
simple c'est comme un jeu d'enfant et il
faut que ça soit facile à faire et je
démystifie beaucoup de choses dans mes
cours démystifier également la crème de
citron ou encore la meringue on fait
chaque fois un petit menu euh et euh
voilà là donc avec des des produits de
saison donc qu'on peut tout de suite
reprendre à la maison c'est aussi des
choses qu'on fait pas forcément
spontanément comme ça
donc c'est toujours sympa d'avoir un pe
une petite recette et justement le fait
d'avoir un guide pour nous montrer un
petit peu placé au four saupoudré de
sucre glace et vos tartelettes au citron
meringué sont prêtes à être
servies
voilà pour cette artelettes qui manque
en plateau on aurait dû les ramener sur
ce plateau on imagine que Valérie oribo
lors de l'atelier a dû forcément se
régaler quand vous faites ces différents
ateliers vous avez encore l'envie la
force de faire la cuisine chez vous
ensuite pas de problème je m'y remets
aussitôt rentrer à la maison parce que
fait la cuisine toute la journé toute la
journée et pour moi de cuisiner c'est
pour les autres c'est du don c'est
êes-vous un bon cuisinier c'est la
question que nous sommes allés poser
dans les rues de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline la parole au téléspectateurs
pour terminer cette séquence micro
trottoir
je pense que je me débrouille pas mal
tout ce qui est à base de fruits de mer
et
de poisson et puis euh puis quoi d'autre
j'aime beaucoup tout ce qui est
asiatique donc je j'ai plaisir à
préparer ce genre de plat
moyen steak frite Ste puis les plat
aussi les pâtes en sauce t ces machins
là quand même ou oui je suis une bonne
cuisinière parce que bah j'ai appris à
regarder avec mes parents voilà du coup
j'ai toujours aimé ça et j'aime bien
cuisiner donc je pense que je me
débrouille pas mal mais plutôt PL Salé
en fait je suis un bon cuisinier mais je
ne cuisine pas avant de me marier
j'étais un très bon cuisinier vous avez
des spécialités oui le soufflet à
l'orange le la pain au pruneau pas trop
je suis pas une très bonne cuisinière
j'aime bien cuisiner de temps en temps
mais seulement les choses un peu sucrées
les gâteaux tout ça ah oui je suis un
bon cuisinier pour la bonne et simple
raison que je sais accommoder à peu près
tout ce qui reste dans le frigo ça a du
goût et ma femme trouve ça bon donc j'en
dédu que je suis un bon cuisinier
av mon cuisinier c'est ça ça ça c'est
finir les restes habilement ouais c'est
de pas faire de gachi et c'était une des
règles du concours c'était surveillé
c'est justement éviter le gâi et ce
qu'on croit qu'il n'est pas bon
justement on peut l'accommoder soit dans
des soupes soit dans des tourtes c'est
les remèes de grand-mère qu'on a un
petit peu oublié parfois et qui
reviennent tout de même en ce moment la
cuisine juste pour conclure c'est une
valeur refuge en temps de crise même en
dehors des temps de crise toute façon
c'est très convivial de se retrouver en
cuisin merci Sylvie Kempler d'être venu
donc en plateau pour le 78 professeur
donc de cuisine à plaisir votre site
internet s'est affiché pour plus
d'informations pour ceux qui voudraient
vous rejoindre prochainement merci à
vous c'est moi qui vous remerci des
étudiants de l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin qui ouvre à nouveau
l'affaire domine ici ils vont nous
expliquer pourquoi dans quelques minutes
maises sport tout d'abord avec cette
rencontre de football féminin entre le
PSG et Montini le Bretonneux pour le
compte des 32e de finale de la Coupe de
France les féminines de Paris
l'emportent 9 à z0ro un résultat qui
passerait presque inaperçu avec
l'arrivée en fin d'après-midi de David
Beckham dans l'équipe masculine mais
pour autant la rédaction était bien
présente hier au stade de La Coudre
résumé Antony reche il ne fallait pas
être en retard au stade de la coudre
queill à froid dès la 2è minute de jeu
les inimontaines se font surprendre sur
l'ouverture du score de la Parisienne
shley Cruise cette première mi-temps
entre Montini et le PSG se résume à une
attaque défense les coéquipières de
kenzadali sont supérieurs techniquement
et physiquement aux inimontaine avec une
circulation de balle à une ou deux
touches les espaces se créent à l'image
de ce débordement côté gauche où la
défense cinquantinoise laisse un
boulevard à l'exceptionnel Lord boulot
qui délivre un modèle de C retrait à
toin
F les vertes n'arrivent pas à se donner
de l'air et rentrer dans le camp
parisien balle au pied aucune occasion
en première période l'addition se sale
très vite 3 4 puis 5 buts à Z0 après les
45 premiè minutes pctué par ce bijou de
coup de pied arrêté
sign tour des vestiaires bis repétita le
PSG version Qatar gère son avance et
accélère le jeu à sa guise de quoi
donner au score une allure de baby foot
grâce au triplet de linoran pour étrier
les vertes 9 buts à
0 il faudra attendre les dernières
minutes de la rencontre pour voir les
inones obtenir leur première occasion de
but la tête de Margo Robin réchauffe les
300 spectateurs mais n'inquiète pas la
gardienne
parisienne les joue de Jean gross pour
consolé en se disant qu'il y a 2 ans
elles avaient perdu 13 à0 face à
l'Olympique Lyonnais en 16e de finale
les féminines du PSG se déplaceront à
tour le 17 février pensionnaire de
division
d'honneur